[Applause]
wiki bear right there and he's yeah he's
got a little switch in the back let me
do that let's turn that on
hello i'm wiki bear what's your name
conan o'brien conan christopher o'brien
television talk show host and former
college intern for massachusetts
congressman robert draymond wow that's
cool that is absolutely right i can
answer any question you have from
wikibear
that's so cool all right wiki bear
what's the world's highest roller
coaster checking now
the world's highest roller coaster is
the 456 foot tall king dakar it's six
flags great adventure in new jersey what
a dizzy drop i'm wiki bear
i didn't know that that's really cool
thank you wiki bear but if you want the
feeling of blood leaving your head don't
ride a coaster get bitten by a black
mamba
one of the most venomous snakes in the
world one bite is enough to kill an
elephant imagine what it could do to a
man yay
okay wikibear i don't think that's
something a kid would need to hear about
just picture it being alone in the
african jungle unable to move or breathe
as your organs shut down in less time
than it takes to make a birthday cake
all right that's fine enough about the
what a roller coaster of muscular
paralysis all right that's fine you pray
for a speedy dance all right thank okay
that's fine wiki bro let's move on let's
change the subject which baseball player
holds the record for consecutive hits in
major league baseball games that
distinction belongs to yankee star
joltin joe dimaggio who hit in 56
consecutive games in 1941 way to go jo
yay oh
that's absolutely right very cool
wikibear but dimaggio's hitting streak
wasn't nearly as hot as the white hot
flames that ripped through the old
coconut grove club in boston the
deadliest nightclub fire in history
it killed 492 people 32 more than the
building's authorized capacity way to
pack them in okay wait a minute no
that's horrific the fire spread so fast
that some victims were found seated at
the bar with drinks in their hands i
hope they had time to scream
[Applause]
no children should be hearing that if
the owners had installed fire doors they
could have saved up to 300 lives but
those doors could have cost nearly 12
bucks hats off to those shrewd
businessmen hey listen
wiki bear now the law forces you to care
about others okay listen wiki bear just
just stop it's not human nature to care
stop
none of this is remotely appropriate for
kids let's change the subject to
something lighter uh
when was the hostess twinkie invented
the twinkie was invented in 1930 by a
baker named james alexander dewer
that's actually really interesting there
you go that's a nice one and speaking of
tasty cakes rasputin the spiritual
advisor to the russian royal family
angered russian nobles so much they
plotted to kill him with cakes filled
with cyanide yum yum okay
we don't want to hear about rasputin
that's a that's a horrible death when
the cakes didn't kill rasputin they shot
him three times kicked him in the face
tied him up and dumped him in a frozen
river while he was still alive that's
the russian can do spirit yeah okay no
it's not
that's terrible that's awful they also
cut off rasputin's penis and saved it in
a jar
look for it on ebay kids
on ebay it's 13 inches long save room on
your bookshelf no
all right
we're going to take a break no more wiki
bear the wealthier above morality
what
you can't handle the truth
[Music]
what are you ad-libbing wikibear
i just want to see pierce president
let's move it along
that wasn't on the script wiki bear deal
with it